i i guess i was the cookie cutter
straight white successful male
um and probably people would look at me
and think well i'm probably like them
and they're for a little bit homophobic
as well
and then i made the really difficult
decision to come out
you know i met a man that i fell in love
with when i was only 40 and then i
realized i was gay
mr do you think homosexuals should be
sent to prison
[Music]
yes
[Music]
when i think about why people are
homophobic i think about a workshop that
i ran in the city a couple of years ago
and
it was really good apart from this one
guy who
literally said nothing and he had his
arms folded
clearly really uncomfortable about being
there
so i stopped the conversation and i
looked at him and i said
i notice you're not engaging with this
you're not
part of the conversation and i said i
suspect there are kind of three things
that i find a lot of people struggle to
engage in this conversation with
and the first one is gay sex lots of
straight men find it very very
uncomfortable to think about how
men have sex with men but we have to
park that we're not having a
conversation around sex we're having a
conversation about
inclusivity and making people feel
welcome
and then i said the second thing i think
lots of people like you think is that
you know that all men who are gay fancy
all
men and i said you're just not my type
and he started to smile and i said but
there's the third thing
and i said this is often a problem is
that if i engage in this conversation
then people might think i'm gay
there is now a deadly virus which anyone
can catch from sex with an infected
person
so protect yourself it's safer if you
use a condom
so i think that crisis had a huge impact
on you know or reinforce the fact that
you know
gay people are different and there was a
lot of terrible language around gay
people spread diseases and you know it
was just ghastly at the time and i think
that's influenced a whole generation
in terms of the way they think about
homosexuality
you know russia has got anti-gay
legislation chechnya
you find programs against oh my god
people if you could speak to vladimir
putin right now what would you say to
him
i would love to sit down and talk to him
face-to-face because only face-to-face
with people do you get any progress so
the thing i particularly like about what
elton says there it's about
sitting down with people and talking i
do think we have repressed
a lot so people have just put it in a
box saying oh god i'm not allowed to say
whatever it may be but if you allow
people time
to say it and to to say words that they
might be a bit clumsy about
it's fine because you can help people
learn
it's fantastic when i talk to young
people who
are declaring whatever spectrum of
sexuality they are on without thinking
about it i think of my own children it's
you know they don't think about this in
the way that you know
those of us born in the 60s and 70s and
the influences that we had
do so is this fixable um
it's changeable it really is and a few
simple things
can help if you've never met a gay
person
go and talk to one you know what they're
quite nice to talk to
and listen and we use something called
reverse mentoring
you know if you're senior go and find
someone that's not like you that is in
the organization
and listen not for you to tell them for
you to listen to their story and who
they are
because it might feel a bit
uncomfortable but trust me that works
brilliantly well and i have seen people
completely transformed their mind is
open
they realize it's they're just like
everyone else being a straight ally i
know that word gets used a lot now
really matters stand up and be counted
and say that you are a supporter of the
lgbt
plus community just do it and you know
what people won't think
worse for you they will think a lot more
of you because it's even more powerful
if a straight ally talks about being
inclusive and being welcoming of
all forms of diversity that works really
[Music]
well
you